il en appelle un jeudi noir les
principales organisations syndicales
relayent l'appel national à la grève
pour protester contre la réforme des
retraites est le secteur qui sera le
plus touché ici c'est l'éducation
nationale les enseignants sont très
remontés contre un futur système de
retraite pénalisant 60% d'entre eux
seront en grève demain dans les écoles
ça veut dire une majorité des écoles qui
seront fermées
incontestablement et on est en train de
voir comment on peut avec les communes à
mettre en place le service minimum
d'accueil
on a mis en place et une information en
continu et une carte interactive sur le
site de l'académie et donc il sera
alimenté au fur et à mesure des
informations qui nous remontent du
terrain pour les collèges et les lycées
un service minimum doit être assurée
même si un proviseur peut refuser
d'accueillir des élèves pour des raisons
de sécurité au niveau des transports
le principal syndicat la cstm n'a pas
appelé à la grève car il n'a pas pour
habitude de relayer les mobilisations
nationales
les perturbations seront donc minime
dans ce secteur tous les autres secteurs
des services publics connaîtront des
perturbations plus ou moins importantes
hôpital poste police pompiers mais les
chiffres de participation ne sont pas
encore connus fosun a appelé dans toutes
ses sections catégorielles à la grève à
la mobilisation nous avons préparé
d'avoir organisé la résistance nous
avons préparé la mobilisation et ça veut
dire que nous nous attendons à une forte
mobilisation
l'appel à la grève du 5 décembre et
reconductible une menace supplémentaire
pour faire plier le gouvernement sur la
réforme des retraites